New York Comic Con live presented by
fandom and twitch we have a very very
special guest here for you and quite a
crowd to see him presenting mr. Stanley
thank you thank you
of course and of course my Marcus TJ we
want to be here stage we were so excited
to meet you Stan and we were so glad
that you're here at Comic Con what has
the experience at Comic Con been like so
far no but he wanted me to do it my
publisher when I suggested the idea he
said that's the worst thing I ever heard
people hate spiders you can't call a
hero spider-man when I said I wanted him
to be a teenager that's where he started
he said to me you don't understand Stan
a teenager can only be a sidekick he
can't be the hero Robin then right then
when I said I wanted to have a lot of
personal problems and nothing ever goes
right from he said Stan don't you know
what a hero is so he wouldn't let me do
it I had to wait till later we had a
book we were gonna drop and when you do
the last issue of a book nobody call a
book and what I call the comic book yeah
nobody cares what you put into it
so I featured spider-man on the cover
and I forgot about it
well a month later the sales figures
came in it had been our biggest seller
so my publisher came to me and said Stan
do you remember that character that we
both liked so much vitamin and what have
you
there we are sorry I can't help myself
all right what's up how y'all doing out
there all right make it good
remember I'm watching but at the same
time I feel they're kind of universal
truths that nobody could quibble with
like to me the most important mantra in
the world is do unto others would you'd
have them do unto you I don't see how
anybody could take issue with that and I
try to follow that and I think if
everybody followed it this would be a
the world would be paradise if you'd
never treat anybody the way you didn't
want to be treated so that that's about
as far as I get into religion just I was
opposed to bigotry as opposed to cruelty
I was opposed to demeaning women or em
other sexes or none of us our other
races or colors or creeds so I would try
occasionally to bring those themes into
the books now very often I'd get fan
mail from people what is your religion
what do you think of Christianity as
opposed to Judaism as opposed to
Buddhism never got into that because I
didn't feel it was our place to get into
that sort of thing so earlier today it
was announced that Stan Lee passed away
which sucks I mean I never knew Stan Lee
personally like I never actually like I
met him but I didn't know Stan I knew
Stan Lee as much as I knew anybody else
like you know I knew about his career
and his contributions but I never knew
him on a personal level but you know
meeting Stan Lee was was amazing and
we'll talk more about that here in a
second but so so let's let's wind the
clock back right one o'clock back a
little while so Stan Lee graduates high
school in like 1939 right and becomes an
assistant at what was
I'm Lee comics at the time now timely
comics was the predecessor to Marvel
iflows you guys who were unfamiliar with
with comic book history let this played
out is you had Superman who came on to
the scene in 1938 right he had Superman
1938 you had Batman in 1939 1940 and you
had and and you had like you know Wonder
Woman and Aquaman and a handful of
others and he had Captain America and
you had name whether Submariner and for
the most part by the time 1941 hit the
comic book industry was off to the races
it was the Silver Age or the Golden Age
of comics you know and and why and
large-caliber superheroes were
intertwined with World War two right I
mean there were a reflection of the
total war effort and you know American
patriotism and so on and so forth but
but Stan Lee was there throughout the
whole thing you know while he was an
assistant he had a couple writing
credits to his name he had some writing
credits to Captain America he had some
writing credits and backup features but
he was by no means you know a Joe Simon
or somebody like that he wasn't on the
same level as guys like that you know
Sheldon Meyer people like that because
he just wasn't contributing in that same
fashion and of course by the time the
the the early 1940s turned into the mid
1940s turned into the late 1940s kind of
looks were at least superheroes were
basically dying out well yeah I mean you
know World War Two was over people saw
comic book superheroes as being
intertwined with world war two and they
didn't really want to read stories about
guys who were fighting against you know
whatever
craziness was going on and said they
want to let their imaginations run wild
right you know so all the Edmond
Hamilton's and these guys started taking
over and then science fiction became the
name of the game and so going into the
1950s Stan Lee's efforts as an assistant
with timely comics began to pay off and
the sense the timely comics under under
Martin Goodman you know under a magazine
management incorporated rebranded itself
and it was no longer timely he was now
Atlas publications and Atlas
publications is basically publishing
comics in almost every genre
except for superheroes westerns and
science fiction and horror and all the
council and Stan Lee had writing credits
to all of those he contributed to so
many of those stories in the 1950s so
that by the time the early 1960s came
around he was an established writer with
some clout
and so in in 1956 DC you know I guess
editor-in-chief Julius Schwartz sat down
and said okay what would happen if we
took science-fiction and we blended it
with superheroes and then release it to
the public what would happen if we did
that and they said well we have a lot of
comics called DC showcase let's
experiment and find out so what the
fourth issue DC showcase number four
Julius Schwartz introduces Barry Allen
and that reignites interest in
superheroes damn superheroes right back
onto the scene again the people are just
like man this is crazy
well well magazine management was
looking for a way to compete with that
they were looking for a way to create
something that could make them a viable
competitor to DC Comics and this was
about six years after the introduction
of Barry Allen and this actually
happened well about you know five years
several of those lines because it's we
1956 in 1960 DC were just like cranking
out a whole new era of superheroes or
reworking existing heroes well you know
Barry Allen gets introduced in DC
showcase number four Hal Jordans
introduced not long after that so the
Green Lantern mythos has reworked
Superman's origin is retold to include
like the fact that on Krypton
Kryptonians had no powers because a red
Sun on earth Superman has powers because
of a Yellow Sun all these different
things were like we're mixed in and
thrown together origins were retold
characters were expanded science fiction
was added to their publications that it
was hugely popular and so by 1960 with
Bravin the bold going into their own
solo series Justice League had like
blown up on the scene and so Stan Lee
goes to Martin Goodman and says we have
a way to compete and the question is how
do we do that and you say we create a
superhero team of our own but for
Stanley
you got lucky look any of the interviews
go back and look at any of the
interviews he done with Larry King any
of those guys and the one thing he'll
always harp on is that he never viewed
superhero comics as being something that
should be too grounded in the real world
it should be grounded in the real world
insofar as it's relatable but the world
was already dark enough as it was we
were post-world War two which meant we
were in the middle of the Cold War you
had McCarthyism in the Red Scare and
people real Stan Lee wanted to create
stories that people could look at as an
escape from what was essentially
considered to be the terrors of the real
world
and so Stanley said okay let's create
the the Fantastic Four let's create it
let's create a team called the Fantastic
Four but it's not gonna be at the
Justice League the Justice League is
wholesome they get along together and
they work together and I kind of go to
all I kind of good stuff
all that kind of cool stuff and the
Fantastic Four will do that but what if
they're like a family and what if like
every family everywhere they they bicker
and they argue and they squabble what if
we do that throw that into the story and
see what happens Stan Lee and Jack Kirby
get together they release Fantastic Four
number one and it sells like gangbusters
it explodes off I mean it just blows off
the shelves and and it's it's insanely
popular at that point Martin Goodman was
like do what it do what you want to do
and so understand Lee and Jack Kirby who
essentially become the one-two punch of
the comic book industry I mean guys like
Steve Ditko and Steve Englehart and Roy
Thomas they were huge contributors you
know but by and large you had Stan Lee
and Jack Kirby who were heads and
shoulders were everybody else but under
those two guys we got Captain America
who returned in Avengers number four we
got the Avengers title Earth's Mightiest
superheroes banding together to face off
against various threats and it was
composed of characters who already had
their own solo series name with a
submariner Iron Man Thor who was popular
and journey into mystery under these
guys the superheroes became this sort of
fantasy element they came out these
really really cool interesting concepts
and they set the groundwork for
everything that would come after with
Marvel Comics the success of Marvel as
it exists now is built on the shoulders
of Stan Lee and Jack Kirby it's built on
the work that they put in and it's built
on the stories they told me and it
really sucks to lose someone who's that
big of a contributor to the comic book
landscape there's somebody who's been
reading comics for so long it sucks to
lose somebody like that you know because
it's just like this guy had a huge hand
in evolving the industry as it exists
but the good thing is that I did get to
meet Stan Lee once and it was actually
kind of interesting first time I ever
met Stan Lee you know first and only
time I actually ever met Stan Lee and it
was it was it was wild because it was
something that I'd always wanted to do
in reality I never pursued an autograph
of Stan Lee to resell it or anything
I always pursued it just for the sake of
having it I want to be able to say I
have something autographed by Stanley
and so I was living in Kentucky at the
time and in a buddy of mine Gordon says
hey man like like we have fan that like
I'm running Fan Expo in Louisville
Kentucky and I say what the hell's Fan
Expo and he says you know what's what's
what's that he's like well think of like
Fan Expo in Canada but like on a smaller
scale and he's like it's right across
the street for Kentucky Kingdom so
literally you can come out here and you
can go to Fan Expo and then like go to
Kentucky Kingdom which is what a lot of
people do what people did at the time
and so I was like yeah sure man because
they had Stan Lee who was coming out
there and it was like was that's always
gonna be the big draw like it a lot of
people out there you know a lot of
people to check it out and so I buy
tickets I roll out there and and I get
out there and realize the comic that I
wanted Stan Lee to autograph I'd left at
home that was this comic Fantastic Four
annual number two this is the original
origin of Doctor Doom tow by Stan Lee
and Jack Kirby funny enough this origin
came out two years after dr. doom
originally debuted because they don't
know what is what they wanted his
wording to be they had no clue what they
wanted him to be they were just kinda
like hey here's a guy who's just like
about as smart as Reed Richards and
usually is as smart sometimes smarter
depending on what the story calls for
super dangerous and he's basically a
blend of like traditional powers and
sorcery and so he's like what if Harry
Potter met superheroes and was like evil
okay so what if Voldemort met
superheroes and like wore metal suit
it's kind of what Doctor Doom is except
uh I think I hit the microphone except
that doctor except Baltimore didn't have
the same kind of one Lantern one-liners
dr. doom has dr. doom head there's this
amazing moment from Jonathan Hickman's
Avengers New Avengers kind of slide
track here for a second this amazing
moment where doctor dooms talking to
Namor the Submariner and he's talking
about being a king talking about being a
ruler and and you know he's you know
he's like he's like you know named
whereas him he's like are you really
gonna sit here and feast in this fashion
why you has people out there you know
who are who aren't feasting in the same
capacity you are and dr. doom asked a
question he says do you really believe
that if they chose to do they would not
be able to rise up and overthrow me he's
like he's like I'm Doctor Doom like you
know yes I rule upon high but I I
protect my people I keep them safe I
give them a better life
so yes Doctor Doom eats first and he
eats the very best I'm just like you
dick but I love you for being a dick it
was it was pretty funny it was pretty
amazing anyway yeah so I wanted to get
that that get that comic signed and I
was so heartbroken that I left it at
home
it was just like damn and that sucks and
I don't want to drive like an hour all
the way back and then an hour all the
way there and so I was like okay
whatever you know I'll just grab a comic
while I'm there and so I'm going through
and I find a variant cover for superior
Iron Man those guys never wrote superior
Iron Man it's one of the coolest stories
ever um it's it's basically our man
becomes a dick like he becomes like Iron
Man from the Marvel Cinematic Universe
but just more of a jerk and so it was it
was a crazy experience right because
they have the table set up in the back
and it's like obviously this is where
Stan Lee's gonna be it's the biggest
section of the of the whole venue and so
there's like this line of people it's
like huge line of people to get him now
I've never had anything autographed by
Stan Lee keep that in mind never had
anything autographed by Stan Lee and so
so I'm standing in this line of people
and they they like they bring Stanley
out and like everybody's like cheering
I'm just like trying man Stan later Stan
Lee like I'm Stan Lee like I'm I was
pretty high so I was really really
excited so they bring him out and of
course like the guy he's pretty old of
the time I mean this was this was you
know five years ago so he was he was
still well into his 90s and so and so
they they they they bring him out they
have him sit down at the table and they
have like this huge bodybuilder guy I'm
just like dude I'm not like I'm guys
here's I mean look like I'll jump into
the thick of it just let you know with
anybody else but like I wouldn't
intentionally look to pick a fight with
that guy so here's so you have you have
a guy who checks the comic right so like
you show up with your comic you have a
guy who checks the comic he looks over
to make sure there's not like razor
blades or anything in there you know
because I imagine they're probably just
crazy people out there he passes the
comic to Stanley Stanley autographs it
like you could say a few words like hey
man I really really love your stuff
before Stanley's even done signing it
The Bodyguard guy has his hand on his on
the comic and then like as soon as
Stanley's done is like here you go like
hands it off to me and it's just like
damn like this is like a slightly lond
but it kind of makes sense too because
you're talking about like one of the
most popular contributors to the history
of comic books doing autographs of
course there's gonna be like a madhouse
it's gonna be insane
like a huge line of people um yeah you
know it's it's the cool thing is I got
to meet Stanley once and and there's
just there's just something about having
you know it's it's there's just
something about being able to say that I
was part of something that one man
helped to usher this is I don't I don't
know I mean I don't really know how to
express that but but you look at the
kind of thing Stanley did and him
alongside you know Jack Kirby and Steve
Ditko and where Thomas and Steve
Englehart and Steve Gerber and you look
at all these guys who have contributed
to them you know to the Marvel landscape
over the years and you say wow you know
that a person could achieve that much
success that a person could have that
huge of an impact on a singular genre is
astounding to me you know it's
incredible to me and so so this this is
this video is really de Stanley you know
like it you know the world has lost an
incredible person the world's lost an
awesome human being you know a great guy
you know that that that really that
brought comics to life in a way that for
me despite the fact that while he was
writer was long before my time
what he did was set in stone alongside
so many other writers and artists
creating a genre that I have been that
that I have spent more time reading than
I haven't read and then I haven't been
reading right like you know I would I'm
still reading how much I was like 11
years old I'm 34 years old now you know
so well 10 years old roughly you know so
I'm 34 years old now but you know I
spend more time reading comics and I
haven't read comics and so much of that
is because of the early work that Stan
Lee put in so much is because of the
early work that they managed to get
together and they managed to sort out so
Stan Lee this one's for you man like it
sucks that you're gone but just know
like you know Stan Lee's leaving behind
an incredible legacy that that so many
people like myself can experience and
enjoy and and be a part of so Stan Lee
rest in peace man hopefully hopefully
you're in a better place so yeah and and
yeah so I will catch you all later peace